hi I'm mark urman and its temper so
we're here to look at new iPhones of
course Apple today introduced the iphone
7 and the iphone 7 plus overall it's a
significant update in terms of speedy
performance at the policy to do a 10
fusion ship to home button here that's
connected to the taptic engine it gives
you some feedback when you touch it it's
not an actual physical click of course
we have the Photos app which shows the
new detail in the pictures and new dual
lens camera lens featuring a larger
iphone 7 plus it allows for deeper zoom
when you actually open up the the camera
app here it has this new optical zoom
feature so you can actually zoom
apple also announced earpods a wireless
version sort of an ex between headphones
and a wouldn't let set then we're going
to take a look at now so these are the
air pots it comes in this charger case
you can charge the case up with a
lightning connector the last year about
24 hours the phone comes out September
16 after September 93 orders and the air
plugs will come out at the end of
October sell some early for 159
according to Apple